[Música]
hola muy buenos días saludamos
nuevamente a la audiencia de france 24
muchísimas gracias por seguir con
nosotros durante los próximos 15 minutos
vamos a abordar la situación en líbano
dos semanas después de la devastadora
explosión ocurrida en la capital en
beirut que dejó a la ciudad
semidestruida el hecho ocurrió cuando el
país ya estaba sumergido en una dura
crisis social política y también
económica y además el país vive hoy una
jornada crucial porque se va a dar a
conocer el tan esperado veredicto en el
caso del asesinato del ex primer
ministro del país rafic hariri en el año
2005 en octubre del año pasado miles de
personas protagonizaron una ola de
protestas rechazando el anuncio de un
aumento impositivo que luego fue
retirado aunque las protestas
continuaron este movimiento inicial fue
el detonante de un descontento
generalizado por la crisis económica la
corrupción la devaluación de la moneda
local el aumento del costo de vida y
también el aumento del desempleo entre
muchos otros conflictos que desembocaron
en masivas protestas y enfrentamientos
además
con las fuerzas de seguridad que se
extendieron hasta abril de este año
cuando llegó la pandemia de coronavirus
y como decíamos en medio de aquella
crisis pero existente el 4 de agosto
llegó una devastadora explosión en el
puerto de beirut que lleva a una caída
del gobierno y cuya solución no se
prevee fácil debido a la sectaria lucha
por el poder
saludamos ahora mismo a nuestra
corresponsal en beirut este el bonete
tel muy buenos días
hola buenos dias santiago este el bueno
contanos porque llega en su peor momento
esta devastación y qué consecuencias
económicas sumadas a las ya existentes
vendrán y tenemos acompañada verdad
si estoy aquí con paula al revés que es
el diseñador ahora mismo diseñadora
amparo por las circunstancias que hay en
el país está la crisis económica y bueno
y todo lo que ha acontecido en este
último año que ha dado a hablar mucho
sobre el líbano y bueno estamos en su
casa con sin cristales en las ventanas
porque ha sido una víctima directa de
esta terrible explosión ella a sus gatos
y sus perros
bueno vamos a andar vamos a continuar
charlando con paola en breve pero te
quería preguntar no como te decían
porque llega en su peor momento esta
devastación no y las consecuencias sin
duda esta explosión ha acabado de
rematar no la economía la moribunda
economía libanesa que ya arrastraba una
deuda de más de 90 mil millones de
dólares desde el mes de octubre y que
además acrecentada por el coronavirus
llevó a una devaluación de la libra
libanesa más del 80 por ciento de su
valor ya una tremenda infracción que
sitúa el líbano en segundo lugar después
de venezuela entonces ahora mismo la
economía libanesa que ya estaba muy muy
dolorida por la situación evidentemente
con los más de 11 mil 11.000 millones
que se espera para la reconstrucción la
situación es terrorífica vamos a
continuar hablando ahora no de las
situaciones de paola no a una de las
afectadas como está enfrentando la
tragedia en estos momentos
pues la verdad es que el país está
intentando no sobreponerse cómo puede
llevar dos semanas intentando todos los
libaneses se han unido han salido a la
calle para intentar desescombrar las
calles del centro de la ciudad que
estaban totalmente devastadas y
desgraciadamente está este acercamiento
entre entre los vecinos también ha
llevado a una terrible situación de un
aumento de casi 400 casos de coronavirus
diarios lo que ha llevado al ministerio
de sanidad a lo mejor a poder declarar
en estas dos siguientes semanas
otra vez el confinamiento imagínate con
la situación económica tan tan difícil
que hay en tener dos semanas más el país
cerrado tiene que ser terrible para la
economía abrimos ahora el puerto de
beirut perdón perdió toda su
infraestructura vital con la explosión
que es lo que viene a partir de ahora ha
sido anunciado algún plan
bueno la verdad es que el puerto de
beirut como dices no es una
infraestructura vital porque el 80% de
los productos alimenticios y
prácticamente de todo entra en el país
de forma importada es decir que el
líbano es un país que lo importa
prácticamente todo y teniendo en cuenta
que el aeropuerto de beirut ha estado
cerrado durante 5 meses debido a la
pandemia el puerto de beirut es el único
la única puerta para la entrada de los
suministros de los materiales de
construcción tan necesarios que se
necesitan ahora para poder reconstruir
más de 8.000 viviendas que han sido
devastadas por esta tremenda explosión
que ha dejado más de 300.000 personas
sin hogar y bueno hay un llamamiento a
la ayuda internacional y todas estas
ayudas se supone que tendrán que llegar
pronto al país pero debido a la crisis a
la crisis política en este caso ya la
dimisión del gobierno quizás vaya a
tardar más tiempo de lo esperado para
que puedan llegar las ayudas en los
hospitales en perú cha estaba en una
situación bastante crítica incluso
previo a la explosión no en este
contexto de pandemia cuáles son
porque me imagino estar agravada por
toda esta tragedia
bueno pues los hospitales son también
una víctima más de esta terrible
explosión porque hay cuatro hospitales
que resultaron gravemente dañados y
están ahora sin poder prestar al
servicio estamos hablando de cuatro los
hospitales más importantes de beirut que
además han habido pues eso hay casos no
de gente que necesita estar tener un
tratamiento diario como por ejemplo los
niños del cáncer que han tenido que
volver a sus casas y además los
suministros de los hospitales también se
han perdido todo lo que son las
medicinas y ahora mismo con el puerto
cerrado todos esos suministros médicos
serán muy difíciles de poder
recuperarlos a ello hay que añadir que
ahora con el aumento de casos de
coronavirus de más de 400 diarios las
camas hospitalarias está prácticamente
desbordado el sistema el sistema
sanitario está regresamos contigo en
unos minutos nada más sobre todo también
para conocer la situación de paola al
revés una ciudad afectada por la
explosión y como adelantábamos esta
explosión ocurrida en el puerto de
beirut la capital de líbano reactivo las
manifestaciones sociales
en líbano que exigen responsabilidades y
también el fin de la élite política
gobernante a la que acusan de ser la
causante de la tragedia debido a su
negligencia y también a la corrupción
que existe en el país desde el inicio de
las masivas protestas a finales de 2019
los libaneses se levantaron en contra de
sus gobernantes exigiendo el fin del
sistema sectario de cuotas que dirige a
este país desde el fin de la guerra
civil los manifestantes reclaman un
gobierno de carácter anti sectario los
detalles los tienen el informe de marina
sardiña
la negligencia y la corrupción de la
élite política culminó en la peor
tragedia en líbano en décadas la
explosión en el puerto de beirut
reactivo con fuerza las protestas
antigubernamentales que iniciaron el
pasado 17 de octubre de 2019 exigiendo
la renuncia de sus gobernantes incapaces
de responder a la emergencia humanitaria
que asola el país como ocurrió en
octubre del año pasado con la dimisión
del ex primer ministro saad hariri la
presión en las calles ha llevado a la
dimisión en bloque del ejecutivo libanés
entre ellos el primer ministro a sandía
en el cargo desde enero continuaremos
empujaremos las protestas todos los días
sin importar lo que pase hasta que
derribemos a todo el estado no sólo al
presidente al parlamento o al primer
ministro todo el mundo debe dimitir
queremos que personas independientes
gobiernen este país
gente que sepa de qué trata este
movimiento gente que represente esta
revolución en el país de los cedros
conviven 18 confesionalidad es
religiosas oficiales fruto de los
acuerdos de taif firmados en 1989 que
pusieron fin a la guerra civil libanesa
y que garantizaba la perpetuación de un
sistema
y las tres principales instituciones
políticas se dividen en el presidente
representado por los cristianos
maronitas el primer ministro de
confesión musulmana sunita y el
presidente del parlamento debe ser un
musulmán chiíta los 128 escaños del
parlamento se reparten en partes iguales
entre cristianos y musulmanes
dificultando la entrada de nuevos
partidos pero este reparto de poder
entre los distintos clanes y señores de
la guerra que cambiaron las armas por
los trajes' llevó el bloqueo político
constante en un gobierno acusado como
deficiente
y la depresión no podemos soportarlo más
que más podemos decir no podemos
soportarlo más ya nadie tolera esta
situación así que nadie debe quedarse en
casa o pensar en no bajar a manifestarse
y esas que el mañanero
mientras las plazas gritan por el fin
del sistema sectario y la convocatoria
de comicios después de una reforma
política
muchos de estos partidos establecidos
desde hace décadas incluido jezbolá y
sus aliados se oponen a la votación
anticipada los libaneses están sumidos
en la reconstrucción de su capital en
ruinas pero la rabia augura también
masivas protestas para la
reconfiguración de sus gobernantes
vamos a regresar ahora con este lunes
nuestra corresponsal en beirut la
capital libanesa que se encuentra como
les adelantábamos acompañada por paola
al revés de ella es una de las afectadas
por la explosión de hace dos semanas en
el puerto de beirut la capital libanesa
es el bueno me imagino que paula está
atravesando una situación muy difícil
como se vió damnificada no es una de las
principales preguntas
sí exacto sea paula tú que eres víctima
directa de esta gran gran tragedia
aparte de las pérdidas materiales y el
dinero que te va a costar poder
reconstruir tu casa que es lo que más
lamenta de lo que ha pasado
lo que más lamento de esa tragedia
gracias a dios no me pasó nada
físicamente todo el daño es material lo
que lamento es la pérdida de esas vidas
inocentes de esa gente que no es
culpable de nada solamente de vivir
cerca de esa zona que es el centro de la
ciudad es una zona muy poblada es
imposible tener materiales inflamables
químicos cual que sean tan cercos de
viviendas es el primer punto que es más
inaceptable el segundo punto es cómo
pueden dejar 30 minutos en el primer la
primera explosión y la segunda en 30
minutos podremos haber salvado muchas
vidas hay sirenas de alarma hay social
media en 5 minutos la noticia hacia el
turno del mundo como puede ser que nadie
nadie pensó en eso solo pensaron en
apagar un fuego que todos sabemos no es
un fuego era un terremoto
paula perdón antes quiero inflar porque
estuve mencionando como paola
previamente te tengo te digo tenéis más
preguntas para la próxima si me quería
preguntarte paula hoy que es un día tan
importante para el líbano no cuando se
va a conocer el histórico
juicio de por por la muerte de rafic
hariri crees que va a haber justicia
también por los culpables de esta de
esta explosión
tiene que tener justicia por los
culpables porque el pueblo la gente no
va a perdonar podemos perdonar muchas
cosas pero arrancar tantas vidas por
nada es inaceptable la gente el dolor de
la gente no va a dejar que pase así
y bueno en tercer lugar me gustaría
preguntarte también paula estas dos
semanas ha habido un aumento de casos de
coronavirus muy grande también porque ha
habido muchísima gente en la calle que
se ha que se ha volcado para ayudar a la
reconstrucción y demás el gobierno
podría declarar en dos semanas que
hubiera otra vez pues eso una un lock
down o como se dice aquí que hubiera
otra vez confinamiento como ves la
situación crees que aparte de esta
terrible explosión y lo que está
viviendo el líbano que haya otra vez un
brote de coronavirus como como crees que
va a ser la situación de aquí al futuro
en 2020 fue el el peor año me parece por
la planeta entera especialmente para el
líbano tuvimos guerra económica la gente
por el coronavirus por lo menos al
inicio la gente controló bastante salía
poco se cuidaba mucho pero desde lavar
la abertura del aeropuerto
parece que el corona desapareció de la
cabeza de la gente con razón hay por día
400 casos que es muchísimo por un país
tan chiquito seguramente el lock down va
a ser muy difícil porque la gente tiene
tanta rabia tanta ira para bajar en la
calle no sé qué va a pasar creo que lo
peor es por adelante
le agradecemos muchísimo por tu
presencia y también a paula por supuesto
por este testimonio en primera persona
acerca de lo que sufrir las
consecuencias de esta explosión a las
dos muchísimas gracias por estar allí
presentes desde beirut en la pantalla de
france 24
gracias paula y gracias santiago a
vosotros no por favor bueno y como
también adelantaba nuestra corresponsal
en beirut de tell bonet otra noticia que
mantiene hoy la atención sobre el líbano
es que se va a dar a conocer el tan
esperado veredicto en el caso del
asesinato del ex primer ministro del
país hablamos de rafic hariri y otras 21
personas ocurrió en el año 2005 aunque
ya se vislumbra una decisión por no
haber evidencias de que el liderazgo de
hezbollah y siria estuvieran implicados
4 integrantes del grupo chiíta libanés
hezbollah están acusados de conspiración
para llevar a cabo el atentado
perpetrado el 14 de febrero de 2005
cuando un camión que contenía al menos
una tonelada de explosivos estaciones
centro de beirut un hecho que sumió a
líbano en una de sus peor
crisis
realizamos esta emisión dedicada al
líbano sigan en frank city 4 in france
24 punto com